I get a lot of really a great emails.
I will get a lot of great
messages through social media,
letters,
written letters,
I get all those kinds of things and I appreciate them all.
I don't always respond to all of them because there's I,
I physically cannot do it.
Yeah.
And of course,
you know,
oh,
get someone to manage your social media or whatever.
I'm not doing that.
If you hear back from me,
you hear it from me,
not from somebody that I paid $10 an hour to respond to my stuff and say,
cool,
get after it.
Like,
no,
I'm not doing that.
But
you know,
I get,
I would get all these things and I,
I do read them,
so if you send it,
I read it.
And so I appreciate the feedback and everything.
I got one though that I,
that was good.
I wanted to actually wanting to read on here because I felt that it not only
said,
hey,
thanks for,
you know,
the podcast or whatever,
thanks for the books,
whatever.
It actually gave some pretty good methodology and really an inset into a mindset
that I think will help people doing what they're doing.
So here we go.
Mr Willick just wanted to share a quick story with you.
At 39 I'd fallen into a 15 year Rut of undisciplined alcoholism.
I was soft and heavy and wanted a change earlier this year.
I had started working out three to four times a week in my basement.
I was trying and failing to get a handle on my alcohol abuse.
Every failure made the beast seem bigger and unbeatable.
It was like I didn't have control over my body.
I finished your book on a Monday night and decided that I would get up early the
next morning and workout.
Okay.
I got up and worked out not much,
but I just wanted to do something.
Sit ups,
pushups,
15 minutes on the bike,
worked out twice Tuesday,
got up Wednesday and did it again.
Got To Thursday night or normal drinking night and decided to try not drinking.
Made it through Friday.
Same thing.
Worked out morning and night,
stayed busy and stayed away from the drink
fault.
I should try and push it through the weekend.
Worked out Saturday morning,
took the rest of the weekend,
often stayed dry.
Monday morning I got up and started two days again.
Okay.
Made it through the week with 11 workouts.
By the second week,
I felt better than I had in my entire life.
I was astounded that normal people walked around feeling this good.
I guess not systematically poisoning your body will do that.
Okay.
On the fifth week,
I got a project at work that was going to require traveling for the next eight
weeks.
I was worried about overcoming my triggers and road habits,
but normal traveling evening was dinner,
watch cable and drink eight beers.
To my surprise,
the hotel at a sweet gym.
Cool.
I'll just keep doing what I'm doing.
Then at the site I found out that weren't,
we would start work at 6:00 AM.
Damn.
That means I have to get up at four to work out.
I'm 12 weeks into my traveling.
Two a days,
usually getting 11 to 12 workouts a week.
They recently moved our start time to 7:00 AM so now I get an hour and a half in
the morning and evening.
I'm 16 weeks clean,
dropped 30 pounds or more.
I haven't been on a scale in three weeks.
34 waist jeans hanging off of me.
I sit up and push.
Upsets went from 10 to 40 to 50 kettlebell swings went from 35 by 10 to 50 by 15
I started to learn how to run as,
I haven't done it in 20 years.
Now after a day off,
I can do two miles without stopping.
I do four to five miles on the treadmill and nine miles on the bike besides the
sit ups,
pushups,
kettle bells,
core and weights.
I look forward to next year's competitive shooting season.
I'm going to bring it at this point,
my cravings are gone and I actually recoil from the smell of booze.
When I started this,
I thought it would be temporary.
Now what's going to be permanent?
No reason to waste time with it anymore.
Now when I questioned something,
your voice comes to me with the hard answer.
It's only black and white with no gray area.
One day when I'm standing before the Lord,
Lord and hear his voice,
if it doesn't sound like yours,
I might be disappointed.
The book I read those months ago was the way of the warrior kid.
I'm working on extreme ownership now.
Thank you for your service.
Thank you for producing a bad ass podcast and thank you for influencing my life.
So
there you go.
And I say this to people all the time.
Most important here is it isn't me,
it's you.
And sure you may have grabbed some little foot hold from the podcast or from one
of the books,
but it isn't me.
That changes you.
It's you.
You set the small goals,
you achieve those goals,
then set some more and achieve those and set some more goals.
Maybe a little bit bigger but not that much bigger.
You pay attention to the progress.
This guy is 16 weeks deep.
Okay?
30 pounds lighter,
working harder,
stronger,
faster,
more efficient,
competitive.
The individual that wrote that is getting after it and changing his life and you
can't too,
just start,
start small.
Start with changing tomorrow morning.
Just tomorrow morning.
Get that squared away.
Okay.
And then move on to the next day and the next,
and move your life to a better place.
One little step.
One little victory at a time.